is it a coincidence that two Republican
elected officials were just shot and
killed in New Jersey in one week
maybe
um is it political it might not be I'm
kind of leaning towards two Republican
officials being shot and killed in the
span of a week I'd at least lean towards
the hypothesis we should look into
whether this is political considering
the rhetoric from the media and
everything like that so if we've got a
democrat in office shouldn't shouldn't
things be calming down at least as far
as the leftist rhetoric is it's it's
more hyped up and amped up than ever
yeah well I think the evolutionaries
that we have to worry about I think the
hyped up rhetoric is what causes a lot
of the right-wing opposition to the
Democrats at church so for example like
people who didn't pay attention to
politics at all four years ago after the
last two years when there's suddenly a
science denying uh you know conspiracy
theorist or whatever and they're an
enemy of intelligence agencies or
whatever suddenly they start to care
about FBI the the FBI having as much
power as it does